why do you think the media loves
covering the films that the two of you
make you don't seem to make big
Hollywood action films right now I've
become sort of mainstay but people
relate to your quirky characters and the
interesting storylines what do you think
that is where does that come into play I
don't know I don't know it is i'm so
glad people like to watch our stuff or
and in particular i don't know what it
is but press loves that may press tends
to love our stuff i really don't know
what it is i mean all I can say oh my
sprinklers are coming on all I can say
is that you know you know we're just I
think it has something to do with the
fact that the stories that we're telling
our very private personal stories that
mark and I are sharing with the world
and I think people feel that and I think
they relate to it because we're I guess
we're telling stories on it we're going
to another level of realism or at least
we're trying to do that you know and
that's what we've heard in terms of
feedback is you know not just audiences
but presses well like oh man that's seen
with this those guys in the bedroom it
was like you had a microphone in my
bedroom last week they were like you
know and and and it's not like we have
figured something out or whatever it's
just we're really we're trying to tell
the truth of what it means to be in
relationships right now and how it
really feels and I think I'm just so
glad that people are feeling it
you